[Music]
as you think about your talent and your
workforce for the for the age of AI and
we're removing - there's there's a few
things that are very important to think
about and I think about two broad
categories of skills that you need to
prepare for one is the talent or the
skills or that the people that do AI you
know who's going to develop the AI those
are the machine learning experts the
data scientists the people with the STEM
skills and coding skills that are going
to build the technology of the future
and that that is an important area that
every organization needs to be preparing
for you know developing and building
those types of skills and that's one
important thing but the bigger set of
skills that I think every organization
is to think about are the people who use
AI not the ones who do in build it but
the people who use AI and that's going
to be basically everybody in the work
force or almost everybody in the work
force in your work force as an
organization and I think that's an area
where organizations haven't spent enough
time everybody knows they have to
develop and hire the AI experts in the
coding experts I think that how the rest
of your organization is going to adapt
and use AI is the big question that
we're really trying to address in human
plus machine there's a few things that
I'd say that are that are really
important there one is is you need to
think about the learning platforms that
you're developing for your organization
one thing that we've we found in the
survey in the research work we did is
2/3 of organizations roughly believe
that their workforce isn't ready for AI
broadly for using AI a big number only
3% of organizations plan to increase
their training spending to account for
that which meat which isn't appropriate
that means that you know generally
people think it's somebody else's
problem to prepare the workforce and we
believe that that that's not the right
answer at Accenture we're investing
about a billion dollars a year in
training and retraining our workforce in
developing talent platforms that
continually retrain people and we think
that that's the approach you need to
take because we're in an age of
continuous innovation the roles of your
workforce are going to continue to
change and you can't flush and replace
the workforce and that's not the right
way to view it how do you how do you
look at your employees as an investable
resource where you're investing in the
talent and developing the right learning
platforms that they can learn how to use
AI in the initial applications or
rolling out now and continue to learn
that their skills are relevant in their
productive contributors to your
organization as you continue to progress
another air that we've really overlooked
in where there's huge potential is using
AI itself to help prepare the workforce
and I think there's huge opportunities
for innovation here we're starting to
see some you know some some real
interesting possibilities coming one
experiment we've done as an organization
this is still in the research and
development stage we've looked at all of
our employees in in in our Accenture
organization we have about over four
hundred thirty thousand people so large
workforce is we've developed a machine
learning model using artificial
intelligence that can take the resumes
and experience of any one of our
employees and this is something our
employees can use to understand how
their job will be impacted by AI and a
soda it might say that you know a feed
and all of your information it'll
compared to external job postings and
trends in the marketplace and it might
say well you've your skills are at risk
in about one to three years and it
doesn't stop there but it says and based
on what you know here's the adjacent
types of you know of jobs that you
should start looking to train yourself
for and again this is a rillette the
research and development stage I
wouldn't say it's it's a product out
there yeah but it shows the kind of
innovation and creativity and way that
we can use technology itself to help
repair the you know prepare workforces
for the changes that are coming down the
road there's a lot of voices out there
they're very well regarded voices Elon
Musk's you know the late Stephen Hawking
who who talked very eloquently about the
perils and dangers that we face with
with AI I do think we need to consider
those and we need to think about the
longer-term implications of AI like like
we do have any technology every
technology that's ever existed from the
first stone wedge that the cavemen you
know you know carved or the first you
know fire that was lit was used for good
and it could be used for bad as well ai
is no different and that the thing that
I think concerns people sometimes the
pace of AI and the ability of AI to make
decisions you know that that that are
not in the interest of us as human
beings the reality is that the risk of
that happening is as far away we do we
should be thinking about it there are
organizations that are set up to think
about those implications and we support
and are involved in some of those
organizations but that's you know for
the distant future not something
we need to think about in our generation
right now in terms of real serious
consequences the opportunity for us now
is to think about how do we apply this
to to live live more effectively on the
planet to better use our resources and
and to operate businesses and
educational institutions and our
governments more effective there's
massive opportunity for this so rather
than be consumed and stuck by you know
what might happen with a technology in
the future we need to think about that
prepare for it but let's apply the
technology in a responsible way which is
what we talked about in human plus
machine to solve these problems today
[Music]